whoa checking the mic hola necesito as
por favor
go to speak Spanish hey what's going on
YouTube yes I know it's been a couple of
weeks I haven't done a video but if you
guys have been following me on Instagram
you guys should already know that I was
pretty pissed at a certain airline it's
[ __ ] Delta [ __ ] flying
pterodactyl tired eating [ __ ] ass
mother [ __ ] we share the story with
you guys as you're so [ __ ] curious so
I went to Hawaii for the past week
ashore so it's why I haven't uploaded
I've been on a vacation mode just to
kind of unwind and [ __ ] so I booked my
ticket about a month ago and of course I
have a guaranteed seat but I told myself
David you're kind of fat you're tall
maybe you need to upgrade your seat so I
decided to upgrade my seat to Delta
comfort Plus to give myself a little
extra legroom
now when you upgrade your seat to Delta
comfort plus it's not guaranteed that
you're going to get the seat that you
want but I check to see if seats were
available and yes they work and so I
decide to go ahead and upgrade I pay for
it and then right as I'm about to choose
my seat I get a notification telling me
that sir you cannot choose your seat
right now you are put on a bail and I'm
kind of like what this is and because
this isn't right I decided to call of
Delta's customer service right hi Delta
Airlines this is Shelly speaking now
this is a simple problem that can easily
be fixed because it wasn't my fault it
was their fault that they decided to not
give me a seat even though it was
something that I already paid for and
yes once again I understand and when you
upgrade it is not guaranteed that you'll
get a specific seat but if you pay for
it that means there is a seat available
for you to get in comfort plus so she
responds but it's not guaranteed that
you'll get the fees that you want when
you go to sales to comfort Plus as you
upgrade and I simply responded yes I
know the problem is is now I'm put on a
veil which means I don't have a seat at
all which is not okay because I booked
this a month ago and her response was
once again sir when you update the Delta
comfort plus it is not guaranteed that
you'll get a seat and so I respond I
understand that seats not guaranteed I
don't think that you understand what I'm
saying but I do understand what you're
saying what I'm saying is that
has lost both my seats and I already
paid for it upgrade so can i least get
my seat back and of course she comes
back with an answer sir we cannot give
you back your old seat because that seat
is gone as well classic but you want to
bail not at this point I'm getting
really frustrated because she's not even
trying to answer my question or help me
out so I told her hey Shelly I'm
frustrated and I understand I'm not mad
at you
I'm mad at the situation continue I
leave empathize with what's going on now
I'm being the [ __ ] nice guy but she
comes back with sir I told you already
that you're seeing and this is my
problem with customer service
you [ __ ] just read off a
[ __ ] page you don't assess the
situation and you don't try to address
the problem you just read off a piece of
a paper and you hear key words and you
just respond to that and don't tell me
[ __ ] like oh my god David you're not in
customer service so you wouldn't [ __ ]
man just because I'm not in customer
service now [ __ ] it doesn't mean
that I wasn't before and every time I
was i assess the situation and I tried
to help out the person and not read
through a pumpkin manual to help people
out
see that's the problem so anyways after
all this is said and then I said one
last thing to her and I just listened
okay Shelly I need you to understand it
this is what happen I paid for the
comfort Plus right which means that you
guys took my money and you charged it
all the way through you already told me
that it's not guaranteed I will get any
specifics tea lights guarantee that I
will get a seat here's the problem I
didn't get either or I got kicked out of
comfort plus and on top of that I lost
my previous seat and now I've put on a
veil for a ticket I already bought a
month ago and was guaranteed a seat do
you not understand the issue I don't
have a seat on this plane after that she
stayed quiet for about 15 to 20 seconds
not saying [ __ ] and then I had to say
hello are you there and she responded
back once again with this sir I already
told you that your seat isn't guaranteed
oh my god
Shelly did you suck a dick so hard that
somehow it flipped right up into your
[ __ ] brain you dumb [ __ ] I hate it
with somebody who's stupid talks to you
like you're done it's like why it's like
when you try to teach a little kid map
right and you tell the kids hey kid
2+2
equals four and then they can't come
back at you like no it's not possibie
like that kind of teach me about mess
four years ago you were a [ __ ] sperm
and egg sex
go [ __ ] yourself baby it is the most
difficult thing having a conversation
with somebody who thinks that they're
actually smarter than you giving you the
right edges when in fact they're
actually dumb as [ __ ] how do you
convince a stupid person that they're
stupid so after all that [ __ ] I
asked for her name she goes my name is
Shelly and of course that's her I got
her name I said Thank You Shelly thanks
for helping me out
adios bye hung up I got on my need and I
pray for God to hit her with the
lightning bolt and I'm hoping that she
got that right between her eyes right it
passed so when I got to Delta there's a
guy that helped me out he gave me the
special ticket saying that I had to be
assigned a specific seat kind of letting
her know my situation when I get to the
gate I was like thank you sir you're so
much better than Shelly that [ __ ]
disease-infested pus face
pitbull dick walk up to the gate lady
and check this [ __ ] out Delta I don't
know who the [ __ ] you are hiring for
your jobs but my god I love related and
tell of my situation but before I even
get to finish my sentence this is what
she said hey there so I need to get a
science search is has a seat now call
your name when we're ready okay but my
situations a little bit different I'm
actually not on a vesser I will call
your name where the seat is available so
I sat down for about 10 minutes and I
started giving out these meats to people
that the receipt that will guarantee to
me and I'm like what's the plug so I
walked up to the desk and of course
right when I walked it before I got to
say anything she said to me sir how many
times like to tell you I told you that I
will call your name up why is everybody
is Delta's mistreating me what the [ __ ]
let oh my god what have I done
what's up what have I done to you
I know how you train your staff Delta
but usually when a customer comes up you
should probably let them finish their
[ __ ] sentence before you tell them to
shut the [ __ ] up and get mad at them
like they're stupid and they're doing
something wrong finally on the last time
that she said it her
can you please I said stop shut the [ __ ]
up and let me finish my sentence or you
keep my [ __ ] interrupting me every
time I try to speak so you can figure
out what the
[ __ ] going on but she stopped he's
quiet and then she said okay fine I'll
let you finish what's the problem so
after I explained to her the situation
in a calm manner not even angry I swear
to God it was super calm and I showed
her my ticket she then says oh okay let
me figure it out she figures it out get
me on the plane get me a decent seat get
my refund back which could have been
done if you just gave the proper
customer service and talking to your
customer base like there are [ __ ]
nuisance and they're done and once again
I don't want to hear this [ __ ] from any
customer service agent saying well this
is the type of [ __ ] we have to go
through on a regular basis so it's okay
to flip out every now and then no it's
[ __ ] not you're in customer service
I've been in it for years and I still
don't do that type of [ __ ] you know
people who say stupid [ __ ] on your
carbon section now go [ __ ] em up it it
ain't no customer service those are dumb
[ __ ] so the moral of story is
is that Shelly you are a [ __ ] god I
swear I hope you're not fired
I know you probably got kids and [ __ ] or
whatever but here's the thing we could
have been friends you and I could have
been in Hawaii right now swimming around
with a bunch of pair of fish with a
[ __ ] a rope attached to my nipples to
the back of the tail to fish floating us
around so we could see mermaids and [ __ ]
them all together what so what I'm
saying Shelly is is that if you ever
ever go outside on a rainy day and you
see an electric pole falling down with
all these sparks flying out of it just
walk up to it put your hand on it and
see what happened I'm not saying I when
she was dead I just want a brains fries
a little bit I feel bad now
[Music]
member